there are new warnings today of
destructive russian malware targeting
organizations in ukraine experts say
that country has long served as a
testing ground for russian cyber attacks
but since russia invaded the battle in
the cyber realm does not match the
intensity of the fighting on the ground
now that has been very surprising to
some of ukraine's allies chris krebs is
cbs news cyber security expert and
analyst he's also former head of the
cyber security for the department of
homeland security that's probably why
you recognize him because he was on tv a
lot back in the day chris krabs it's
really good to see you this morning you
know people thought there would be this
massive cyber security attack it has not
happened yet why do you think that's the
case
well good morning and thanks for having
me on yeah i think the folks i've talked
to uh my own opinion it is somewhat
surprising that we did not see more
activity in the preparatory stages of
the russian invasion and that's frankly
where cyber attacks are most useful it's
in the gray zone it's before you have
actual kinetic troops on the ground in
part it may have been uh and this is the
opinion of others and i tend to share it
is that the russian strategy was based
on speed and they depended on ukrainians
to surrender and so attacking
infrastructure bringing it down and then
having to rebuild it
would not have been in the strategic
interest of of the russians and so you
know perhaps they they miscalculated
here but what it is allowed is given the
fact that the telecommunications
networks are up the ukrainians have been
able to really own the information space
and they own the narratives the iconic
images of the last four or five days all
belong to the ukrainians and certainly
not the russians
chris can you talk about what the
russians are capable of when it comes to
cyber attacks and the damage that that
could cause and would cause
well the russians are very capable
they've launched a number of attacks in
ukraine previously 2015 and 2016. they
took down the electrical grid 2017 they
launched a destructive a global attack
known as not petcha that caused 200 to
300 billion dollars in damage so they
are quite capable they also host and
provide safe harbor to uh cyber
criminals ransomware gangs and so as i
think we look forward the potential is
continued espionage campaigns against
global governments but as well as
perhaps enabling ransomware actors to go
after american businesses and western
businesses and i'd point out that as the
the sanctions continue to lay waste to
the russian economy and it may become an
economic necessity for ransomware actors
to uh strike out and bring in revenue or
money back into russia
so chris you mentioned the potential for
strikes here in the u.s putin has made
very clear that he sees america as the
ultimate villain in this fight so i
would expect a cyber attack could come
here
what are the risks on that front and
what can everyday americans do if they
want to secure say their bank account or
their retirement account
well you know i think the general level
of risk is still fairly low absent any
direct engagement between the u.s and
the russians and i'm talking between
russian
security service forces however the the
us government has been engaged with the
critical infrastructure community the
banks the energy companies for quite
some time i'm talking uh
months and specific to the russian
invasion of ukraine to increase the
level of resilience you know 100
security is is never really the
objective it's it's not effective and so
they've been identifying those critical
aspects of the
the industry to ensure that they can
respond effectively to any sort of
attack now individuals keep your devices
updated for your bank accounts or other
sensitive accounts make sure you have
multi-factor authentication enabled and
that's where you either take a an email
or some other sort of communication
including an application an
authenticating application to ensure
that it's you logging into that device
the last thing i point out tony is that
be on the lookout for scams and grifters
just like any other tragic event there
are those that try to profit off of it
so keep an eye on those emails those
those text messages those phone calls
that come in and ask for donations make
sure you vet who is asking for money
before you get before you donate
chris uh the u.s and ukraine's other
western allies have offensive cyber
weapons what does that look like exactly
well the u.s and a number of our
european allies are as good if not
better than anyone else out there so i
think what you would be seeing probably
right now is activities to ensure that
the russians cannot launch offensive
cyber action so it's more all playing
offense for better defense so going
after their servers and command and
control infrastructure as it's known to
ensure that they can't launch anything
here kind of putting sand in their gears
to make it harder to operate also
looking at some of the disinformation
operations that the russians may be
using to launder their narratives and
push their propaganda to make sure that
those those don't get out of the uh of
russia and taint the airwaves
we are all on high alert chris thank you